>> Peter Vankevich: Okay, folks,
we'll go ahead and get started.
Please take your seats.
Before we start I
want to do a shout
out for our ASL interpreters
over here
who do a wonderful
job every year.
[ Applause ]
Okay we're back and
running here.
So I just want to briefly
introduce you to Sydney Trent.
She's the social issues editor
over at the Washington Post.
The Washington Post
has been a good friend
of this Book Festival I think
right from the start so.
[ Applause ]
And I'll tell you I live
in North Carolina I
pay a subscription to,
that's my paper.
So, anyway, Sydney, welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Sydney Trent: Good
afternoon everybody.
I am Sydney Trent, and
I'm social issues editor
at the Washington Post,
which is a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
First a word of thanks to the
cochairmen of the festival,
David Rubenstein, and the
other generous sponsors
who have made this
event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
please note the information
in your program.
We'll have some time after this
presentation for your questions,
and I've been asked to
remind you that if you come
to the microphone you will
be included in the videotape
of this event, which may be
broadcast at a later date.
I was particularly
excited to be asked
to introduce this
author, Tayari Jones.
[ Applause ]
I read her book, An American
Marriage, recently as part
of my book club and was struck
by what an inspired idea it was
to focus on the emotional impact
of black male incarceration
in a work of fiction.
We are all familiar with
this as a topic in the news,
but Jones's perceptive
and compassionate narrative
voice reveals the full
dimensions of the damage
that unjust incarceration has
on African-American couples,
their families and
the human spirit.
Jones is the author of novels,
Leaving Atlanta, the Untelling,
Silver Sparrow and
An American Marriage.
Her writing has appeared
in Tin House, The Believer,
the New York Times and Callalo.
A member of the Fellowship
of Southern Writers,
she has also been a recipient of
the Hurst-Wright Legacy Award,
Lifetime Achievement
Award in Fine Arts
from the Congressional
Black Caucus Foundation,
the United States Artist
Fellowship, NEA Fellowship
and Radcliffe Institute
Bunting Fellowship.
Silver Sparrow was added
to the NEA Big Read
Library of Classics in 2016.
[ Applause ]
Jones is a graduate of Spelman
College, University of Iowa
and Arizona State University.
She is a professor of creative
writing at Emory University
and now I introduce
Tayari Jones.
[ Applause ]
>> Tayari Jones:
Thank you so much
for that generous introduction
and for the invitation
to be here today and thank you
to all of you for believing
in literature and books.
This is a holiday weekend.
Ya'll could be doing
other things.
So, on behalf of everyone
who's ever written a book,
everyone's ever wanted to read
a book, who has ever wanted
to write a book,
thank you for choosing
to spend your weekend this way.
It means so much because
when you write a novel
in some ways you
feel like you're
like you're sending
a letter in a bottle.
You spent all this time writing
on it and you throw it out there
and you don't know if
it'll ever reach anyone.
And so for all of you to show up
today not just for this session
but for all the sessions
I just want to thank you
on behalf of all of us.
[ Applause ]
I came to the National
Book Festival
for the first time seven
years ago with my last book,
and I was there as a guest of
the NEA, the National Endowment
for the Arts, and I want
to just take a moment
to tell you all how much
these national programs mean
to writers who are
just starting out.
The NEA nurtures talent back
like when I wrote my
first three books,
basically nobody read them
but my mother and the NEA.
[Laughter] And I was given
a grant which allowed me
to take some time off and
work on my book and then
when the book was out the
NEA selected me to come
to the National Book Festival,
and that was the first time
I had ever spoken to a room
with more than say 50 people
in it and it meant a lot to me
as a writer and also as an
American citizen to be supported
like that as an artist
by the government.
And the NEA as you know
is in a position now
where it's fighting
for its life.
So should you ever find
yourself in the company
of your Congress person
or anybody with any clout
or even anybody without clout
tell them how much the NEA means
to all of us.
[ Applause ]
When we were invited
here they said, you know,
you talk about your book
and you talk about yourself
and I was thinking should I talk
about my books or should I talk
about myself, but I realized
on some level they're
the same thing.
And like I said I was
here seven years ago
and when I was here seven years
ago the world was very different
than it is now and I was
very, my life is different.
So I was thinking, well, who am
I now versus seven years ago?
When I came here seven years
ago, my message really was
to tell everyone out there who
has a dream, who has a passion,
to follow it, that if you do
your part to follow your dreams
and your passion then
the universe, God,
however you do it
will meet you halfway
because my life has been full of
stories of times when it looked
like I would not be a writer.
There are times it looked
like I wouldn't continue
to be a writer, but
I gave it my all.
I started writing when I was a
kid, I was like 16 years old,
and I knew that I
liked to write.
I had little notebooks
and everything,
but when I was a teenager, if
you were a girl and you liked
to read and you liked to write,
people didn't think it
meant you were a writer
or an intellectual, people
thought it meant you were nice.
Because when I was coming
up if you're a girl,
you were either a nice
girl or a not nice girl
and that was the only
question and if you liked
to read all the time,
then you were nice.
I used to say because
no one ever got pregnant
in the library, but librarians
always raise their hand
and say that's not true.
[Laughter] So I'll say that
a few people get pregnant
in the library, But when
I went to college I went
to Spelman College which is
a women's college in Atlanta
and it was there that I met a
writer and she was my teacher.
Her name was Pearl Kleg,
and I took her class
freshman were not allowed
to take this class, but I had
never met a writer before,
and I wanted to be in the
class and I thought it over
and things were not
computerized in the late 80s
so there was a lot
more wiggle room
in creating your own narrative
shall we say and you had
to get your advisor to
sign to give you permission
to take a class that
was above your level.
And I figured my
advisor had a lot
of advisees she wouldn't
remember me so what
if I just kind of were to
sign her name a little bit
to get into this class?
So I did this and I signed
up and I got into this class
and the advisor called
me in and, you know,
she said this is not
my signature and I was
like yes ma'am, I'm
sorry, but she said to me
that if a kid wants to take
a class, like if you're,
if the kid is doing
basically fraud but in order
to take a class, let
her take that class.
So I promised never
to commit fraud again
and to this day I have not but I
took the class and the teacher,
Pearl Kleg, said to me what
are you thinking about?
And I got ready to tell her
what I was thinking about.
She says no don't tell
me, write it down.
And in that she became my first
audience and so I worked hard
because I wanted to write
down what I was thinking,
and I wanted to follow the
example she set for me,
and I wanted to be a writer,
but I didn't know how to go
from being a college
student to being a writer.
When I finished school, I didn't
even know there was a such thing
as a graduate program
in creative writing.
I thought writers just were, and
I didn't know what I was going
to do with my life and
everyone was pushing me
to do a PhD in literature.
Everyone said, oh, you can
be a professor, you can write
on the weekends, right?
Don't worry about it.
And I didn't want to do it
because I felt like I was a bird
and they wanted me to
become a birdwatcher
but I was also very
young so I went
to do this PhD and
I didn't like it.
I felt I was like I was, I
felt like I was my face pressed
to the glass of what
I really wanted to do.
And so I wrote to Pearl and told
her I'm so unhappy, you know,
I don't want to be here and
she said to me well just quit.
And I was like I can't
quite, you know, I was raised
like probably many of you, you
have to finish what you start,
and I felt that being there
I was representing myself,
I was representing my family,
I was represented my college,
I felt like I was representing
black people everywhere and that
if I were to leave then anyone
who had anything in common
with me would never have the
opportunity to go to school
to get a PhD there but Pearl
said that's not how it works.
I was like really?
She's like, no, people
quit things all the time.
I said are you sure?
She said, oh, yeah, so I just
wrote the people a letter.
I didn't say I quit.
I said a lot of things, thank
you for this opportunity,
et cetera, et cetera,
then I said I quit,
and I started trying
to write a novel.
I wanted to write a novel
about my experiences growing
up in Atlanta during the
Atlanta child murders.
When I was a kid, 28 black
children were murdered
in Atlanta and two
of them were children
in my elementary school.
I wanted to write a novel
not about the murders.
I didn't want to turn my
childhood into an episode of Law
and Order, or true
crime or thriller,
I wanted to write what
it was like to be a child
in the early 80s and this was
happening because someone said
to me, oh, you must not have had
a childhood and my feeling was,
you know, we did
have a childhood.
Our childhood intersected
with this tragedy,
but our lives were not a tragedy
and that became my mission
in writing this book and so I
didn't know how to go about it,
but I started it and
this is what I'm saying
about when you dedicate yourself
to something with
all your hear,.
I literally ran into a writer
who directed our creative
writing program and she's here.
She's at a different stage.
I think we're speaking
simultaneously.
Her name is Jewell Parker Rhodes
and I met her and she said come
to Arizona and work with me.
She said I'll help you,
I'll be your mentor.
And I said oh no, ma'am,
I can't move to Arizona.
I said it' hot out there.
[Laughter] And this
was in the early 90.
Do you remember when they didn't
have the King holiday out there?
And I said they don't
have the King holiday
and she said it's only hot
in the summertime there
has been a voter referendum
and I will have you
a King holiday
by the time you get there.
[Laughter] So I felt like it was
my own personal King holiday.
So I told my, I was in my 20s
I told my parents I'm moving
to Arizona.
They're like you
can't move to Arizona.
You don't know anyone out
there, it's hot out there
and besides they don't
have the King holiday.
And I said actually there's been
a voter referendum and so I went
out there and I wrote
my first book,
and I felt really good about,
I felt that I had done my,
I was doing my life's work.
You know I probably, I
didn't sell very many copies,
I didn't earn out my advanced,
no one had ever heard of me
that wasn't related to
me, but I felt like I had,
I was doing what
I was meant to do,
but life is full of challenges.
When I wrote my third
book, I turned it in
and they had computers.
Remember I said there weren't
computers in the beginning?
There are computers now
and the computers have,
there's a computer program.
Those of you who are in
the business will know it
but is called BookScan.
BookScan means they can put
your name in the computer
and see exactly how
many books you've sold.
You used to could fake it.
You could act successful
and people would think
you were successful,
but now there's this
computer program that says
like don't believe the hype
and it gives an exact number
of how many books you have sold.
So for my second book, my third
book, I couldn't get a contract
because of my BookScan,
and I felt really defeated
by this computer program.
You know it was so exact and
so declarative, not profitable.
So I didn't want to
continue writing the book
but the book was
important to me.
It was a book I had written
about my relationship
with my sister.
I have a sister, we
weren't raised together,
we lived completely different
lives, but all my life I felt
like I both had a sister
and didn't have a sister.
Like I had a sister
who was right there
in my peripheral vision,
but when I turned my head,
there was no one there.
And I wanted to write this novel
for everyone who has siblings
that you didn't grow up with but
you feel connected with them,
but you don't know
how to bridge the gap.
So I knew I had to finish
writing this book even though I
had been all but promised that
I would never have a publisher
for it because of this BookScan.
Well, I wrote the book,
I started writing it,
and then I got a mysterious
phone call and it was,
the area code was from LA.
I have one friend in
LA he's very successful
and when things don't
go 100% right for him,
he calls me to complain.
At this point in my life things
were going 98% wrong for me,
and I did not want
to hear him talk
about his slight disappointment,
but I thought okay that's
not being a good friend
so I answered the
phone and the person
on the phone said
they were calling me
from an arts organization called
United States Artist Foundation.
I thought they were
telemarketing me,
and I felt like this was not
a good time for me to be asked
to give money to other people
because I have no money,
And they said no, no, no,
We're calling to support you
as a writer, we would
like to give you money
to spend a year to
work on your book.
And being honest I said well,
I told about the BookScan.
I said I don't think I'll
be able to publish this book
and they said we don't care
about BookScan, we don't care
about numbers, we care about
art and artists' stories.
[ Applause ]
So I took that year off,
I finished the book,
and I put the book in a drawer
because I just didn't know
how I could publish it,
but I knew I had done my part.
I feel like when you're given
a gift all God asks of you is
that you use that gift,
the rest that's his job
for me just finish the book.
So I finished the book
and I put it in a drawer.
I had one activity left
on my schedule as a writer
and I had been invited
to a literary seminar
to give a reading, and
I didn't want to go
but I had already said yes and,
you know, again always felt
like I was representing
everybody
and if I didn't go ruin it,
you know, that same story.
I feel like that story,
that idea of thinking
is probably going
to follow me the
rest of my life.
This feeling of letting
down the entire race
if you don't show up.
So I went to the thing
in Florida but the day,
like a week before the
Florida people called me
and said we can't get
your existing books
because your books
are out of print.
Now when your books
are out of print
that means they're not
printing them anymore
like it never happened, and I
was like that's impossible but,
no, it was possible
because of the what?
BookScan. So but I went to
Florida and I was embarrassed
because I felt that I
would give a reading
and I wouldn't have any books
to sign and people would say
where are you books
and I would have
to say my books are
out of print.
Because of BookScan I
can't get a book contract,
but I went anyway
and when I got there,
the bookseller had 4 copies
of my books, 1, 2, 3, 4,
and I said where
did you get those?
And he said, oh, they
came in this book
and they showed me the box
and I recognized my father's
very distinct handwriting.
And I called him and I
said, daddy, he said,
yeah, I sent my books.
He said and I went
to your uncle's house
and I got his books.
He said, he said those books
were unread, they're brand new,
your uncle hadn't
even looked at them.
[Laughter] And so and daddy
said so this is what you'll do.
You sign those 4 books
and when anyone else comes
up to your signing table you
just tell them you sold out.
[Laughter] So I read from my
work in progress and I sat
down at the signing table
and I signed the 4 books
and then a woman came up to me
and she wanted a book signed,
and I said oh, I'm
so sorry I sold out,
and she said oh that's good
because I heard that, you know,
you're having a hard time
with your BookScan and I heard
that your books are out
of print, and I was dying
because I had gone through
all this trouble to pretend
like this wasn't happening,
but the woman said I
think I can help you.
Now, if you're a writer you know
there are all kinds of people
who think they can help
you, they have all kinds
of crazy schemes, their uncle
might have a printing press
in the basement you
just don't know,
but she said I can help you
and she took me by the hand
and she carried me
through the crowd
and she literally put my hand
in the hand of another woman,
whom I recognized as a
publisher and I recognized her
because they had
already rejected my book
because of what?
BookScan. I hate BookScan
so much, but anyway
and the woman asked me she
said what is your book about?
I said it's about 2 girls
they have the same father,
but only one of them knows.
She said that's interesting.
You should send it to me, but I
was embarrassed because I knew
that the company had already
rejected me and I was trying
to get away but that lady
she had my hand like this.
And finally as I got away she
said wait before you go she
said, you know, how
do you know Judy?
And I said, oh, I don't
know anyone named Judy.
And she says, no, no, no, Judy
Bloom who just introduced us.
It was as though my nerdy
childhood had come to rescue me
in my time of need, and I
looked to tell her thank you
and she had vanished like
a real fairy godmother.
And y'all within a week my
career was back on track.
[ Applause ]
I love to say it's a true story,
and that book was
called Silver Sparrow
and my publisher was back, I
had a publisher things were back
and that's the book that got me
to the festival the last time I
was here, and I felt really good
about it, but again this life
as an artist it keeps
challenging you to grow
and do something different.
So when it came time to write my
fourth novel, I had a publisher,
I didn't have to
worry about that,
my BookScan was fine thank
you very much, but I wanted
to write a novel about something
bigger than my own life.
I wanted to write something
about, something meaningful.
Like all of you I noticed that
the world seems to be on fire,
and I felt that as a writer part
of my job is, all of our job is
to try to put out the
flames with whatever we have
and what I have is my pen and
so I wanted to write a novel
to do something about
wrongful incarceration
and so I wrote a grant and I was
accepted to Harvard University
to do research on the topic.
And I did all this research
I discovered terrible things
like did you know that
at any given moment
over 2.5 million
people are in prison?
Over 4 million people are
on parole or on probation.
Here in Washington, D.C.,
1 out of 4 black men will
at some time be in
jail or in prison.
One out of 28 American children
have a parent who is in prison.
Every time anyone is in
prison, it represents a kind
of family separation because
we are all members of a family,
and I wanted to write
something about this,
but I had these statistics,
but I didn't have a story.
A problem is not a story,
a situation is not a story,
and I didn't know what to do.
So here I am at Harvard they
want us to give a presentation
on our work and all
I have to show
for my time there is a very
underlined, battered copy
of the new Jim Crow, a whole
stack of angry index cards
but no story, and I
didn't know what to do.
I went home to Atlanta where
I'm from to spend some time
with my mother, which
I do when I'm upset,
and while I was there I
spent some time at the mall,
which I do when I'm upset.
[Laughter] And when I was at the
mall I heard a couple arguing.
The woman was fantastically
dressed.
She looked just gorgeous and the
guy she was with he looked fine,
he looked okay, but she
looked great, and I could tell
that they were in
love and in trouble,
and I heard her say clear
as a bell she said, Roy,
you know you wouldn't have
waited on me for seven years.
And I was interested.
I didn't know him, I didn't
know her, but I was looking
and I felt like you're
right, girl,
he probably would not have
waited on you for seven years,
and he looked at her and he said
I don't know what you're talking
about because this
wouldn't have happened
to you in the first place.
And I looked at her and
I thought, you're right,
this probably wouldn't
have happened to her.
[Laughter] And for me I know I
have a novel when I'm writing
from a place where both
people are telling the truth,
both people are right
and both people are wrong
because when I do that,
I have a moral quandary.
So, An American Marriage is
a story of a young couple
who are only married 18 months
when the husband is arrested
for a crime he does not commit.
As she says, I don't
know if I was yet a wife
or if I was still
a bride, you know,
she said I was still combing
the rice out of my hair.
Her daddy is still paying for
the wedding when he is arrested
and given a lengthy sentence.
And then the question
is this what is loyalty?
How do we take care of one
another in times of crisis?
The question of what is selfish?
Is it more selfish if she
wants to live her own life
or is it more selfish for him
to not want her to
live her own life?
How do we make compromises?
And so I started
writing this novel.
When I first started writing it,
I wrote it all from the point
of view of the wife, Celestial,
because I'm a southern writer
and southern novels
are all about women
who don't do what they're told.
And I wrote it but it didn't
feel like the whole truth.
So then I wrote the whole novel
a second time all from his point
of view, the man who has been
stripped of everything he worked
for and put into
prison and has to figure
out how to find his way back.
And when I wrote that,
it still, it was easy,
but it didn't feel right because
I realized it was a story I
heard so many times before.
I realized that it
essentially was the same story
as the Odyssey that I read
in high school, right?
Like Odysseys he just is
facing all these trials
and he just wants to come home
to a faithful woman
and a clean house.
And that was written
in 70 BC, right?
So I was like what is
the update of that story?
And then I decided I heard
Claudia Rankin read from a poem
from her collection, Citizen,
and I used it as the epigraph
of this book and it says what
happens to you doesn't belong
to you only half concerns you
it's not yours, not yours only.
And I realized that this
story was not his story
or her story it was their story,
and I toggled their points
of view, but it still
didn't feel complete
because I don't think
it's a spoiler to say this
but An American Marriage
is a story about justice,
it's a love story and
it's also a love triangle.
And so I added the
voice of another man
and when I had all three
of their voices I felt
like I had the whole
story of what happens
when people are forced to make
decisions they shouldn't have
to make in the first place.
I thought I would end my talk
by reading to you just a couple
of pages from the first chapter
and then I thought we
could take some questions.
I have to put on my
glasses because lately
like when I turned 40 all the
words in books became so small.
Write to your Congressman
about that.
[Laughter] This is from the
point of view of Celestial
on the day of Roy's trial.
"What I know is this
they didn't believe me.
Twelve people and not one
of them took me at my word.
There in the front of
the room I explained
that Roy couldn't have
raped the woman in Room 206
because we had been together.
I told them about the magic
fingers that wouldn't work,
about the movie that played
on the snowy television.
The prosecutor asked me what
we had been fighting about.
Rattled I looked to Roy
and to both our mothers.
[Inaudible] subjective so
I didn't have to answer,
but the pause made it appear
that I was concealing
something rotten at the pit
of our very young marriage.
Even before I stepped down
from the witness stand,
I knew that I had failed him.
Maybe I wasn't appealing
enough, not dramatic enough
to not from around here.
Who knows.
Uncle Banks coaching me had
said now is not the time
to be articulate, now was the
time to give it up, no filter,
all heart no matter what you're
asked, what you want the jury
to see is why you married him.
I tried, but I didn't know
how to be anything other
than well spoken in
front of strangers.
I wish I could have
brought a selection
of my art work all
images of Roy.
I would then say this
is who he is to me.
Isn't he beautiful?
Isn't he gentle?
But all I had were words, which
are light and flimsy as air.
As I took my seat, not even
the black lady juror would look
at me.
Time turns out that I
watched too much television.
I was expecting a scientist
to come and testify about DNA.
I was waiting for a pair of
handsome detectives to burst
into the courtroom at the
last minute whispering
something urgent.
Everyone would see that
this was a big mistake,
a major misunderstanding.
We would all be shaken
but appeased.
I fully believed that I
would leave the courtroom
with my husband beside me.
Secure in our home we would
tell people how no black man is
really safe in America, but 12
years is what they gave him.
We would be 43 years old
when he was released.
Roy understood that 12
years was an eternity
because he sobbed right there
at the defendant's table,
his knees gave way and
he fell into his chair.
The judge paused and demanded
Roy bear this news on his feet.
He stood again and cried
not like a baby but in a way
that only a grown man can cry
from the bottom of his feet
up through his torso and
finally through his mouth.
When a man wails like that,
you know it's all the tears
he was never allowed to shed.
As Roy howled, my fingers
kept worrying a rough patch
of skin beneath my skin.
A souvenir of scar tissue.
When they did what I remember
as kicking in the door,
what everyone else remembers
as opening it with a key,
after the door was opened
however it was opened,
we were both pulled
from the bed.
They dragged Roy
into the parking lot
and I followed lunging
for him wearing nothing
but a white slip.
Someone pushed me to the ground
and my chin hit the pavement.
My skip rode up showing
everything to everyone
and my tooth sank into the
soft skin of my bottom lip.
Roy was on the asphalt beside me
barely beyond my grasp speaking
words that didn't reach my ears.
I don't know how long
we lay there parallel
like burial plots,
husband, wife,
what God has brought together
let no man tear asunder."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now I'm happy to
take your questions.
Don't be shy.
I'm nice. Come on up.
>> Hi.
>> Tayari Jones: Hi.
>> I really loved the book
you had about your sister
and I was wondering just having
written a lot very personal
stories to you how do
you feel about Celestial
and all the world you created
in An American Marriage?
Are they kind of your family
now in a sense or what's it
like to come up with
characters that aren't going
to be your own, your own life?
>> Tayari Jones: You know when
I was writing this at first
when I started writing I felt
I was so far away from my life,
you know, Celestial's
husband is arrested
for a crime he doesn't commit,
you know, I don't have a husband
at all let alone one
that's been arrested
for a crime he didn't
commit, but what I realized is
that the thing that made
this story moving for me
to write is the extent to which
her problems were the same
as their problems as
a couple are the same
as all couples it's
just that it's turned
up so much higher for them.
Like the question at the heart
of her predicament is how much
of yourself do you devote
to your relationship
and how much do you hold
back for your own dreams?
I mean that's her question
it's just so much more intense
and that also made
it heartbreaking
because it really added a deeper
human dimension to the issue
when I think about questions
of mass incarceration
that they are just like us
because they are just like us
and the deprivation of their
rights is just the same
as the deprivation
of yours or mine.
>> Thank you.
>> I want to thank you for
the gift of your books.
>> Tayari Jones: Oh, thank you.
>> And ask you whether
you might share
with us what you're
working on now.
>> Tayari Jones: The question
is what is working on me?
[Laughter] I'm trying
to work on a new novel.
I'm not sure of the angle.
See my feeling is like if you
have a real life experience
that makes you think
there's a novel there,
you don't quite know
the angle yet,
but I will tell you this
thing that happened to me
when I was a little girl
that I've been wondering
about ever since.
When I was 12 years old, I went
to a wedding and we were sitting
out there in the
pews all dressed up
and the bride didn't come
down the aisle for 2 hours.
And so we went in the
back me and my mom
and there was a bride,
she looked so pretty
but she was crying.
She did not want to marry him
and she was, I mean her mother,
I mean everyone was there, the
reception, everything was set
and one of her bridesmaids
said I have an idea.
How about you go through the
ceremony, walk down the aisle,
just don't file the papers.
[Laughter] That way no one is
embarrassed, you don't have
to actually be married and
you get to keep the toaster.
[Laughter] And I have
always wondered two things.
Why didn't she want to marry him
and at what point did she
tell him she wasn't filing
the papers?
[Laughter] You see?
So I think that that's
at the center of a story,
there's something in there that
I want to tease out like what
but I don't know what, but
I'm in there somewhere.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi, how are you?
>> Tayari Jones: Hello.
>> I was wondering, well,
first of all I wanted
to say I love your book and
I've never had the experience
of having a parent
be incarcerated,
but I can definitely relate
to the emotion of sort
of the separation and this idea
of, you know, sort of being
in a quandary like you
follow this relationship
or do you follow your own
dreams like you were saying?
But I also wanted to ask looking
at you kind of Celestial kind
of reminds me of actually you
from an aesthetic perspective.
[Laughter] And I was
just wondering, you know,
are there people in your life
that you model the character's
personality wise after
or like how do you
develop the characters
as people when you're writing?
>> Well, you're right she
does look like me doesn't she?
[Laughter] Well, also I have
been this tall since I was
about 13 years old so I
do try, when I was a kid
and being this tall, I never
read about a woman or a girl
that people desired
that were this tall.
So I did kind of do
that as just a gesture
of love to my teenage self.
[Laughter]
[ Applause ]
I mean I think we all, I think
we all have things that we just,
we wish we could go in a time
machine and give ourselves,
you know, a hug or just a
little heads up from the future
to say it's going to be fine,
it's going to be fine just hang
in there, but with other
characters I do sort of,
I have a friend who swears
up and down that I steal all
of his best lines and
put them in my books.
I'm like I don't steal them,
you still have them, you know,
but I do try to capture the
way I think people really talk
because I think that something
that we can do in fiction
that our peers and like if I
was writing a non-fiction book
about wrongful incarceration,
I wouldn't be able
to capture the things about
the culture that will never be
in like a scholarly text,
the funny things people say,
what people do, little love
notes to people in my life
to let them know that I am
watching them and seeing them,
but I try not to stick
too closely to one person
because if I model a character
off of a person, then I start
to feel like if I let the
character do something else the
real life person will
feel like I'm lying
on them or judging them.
So I try, whenever
it feels too close,
I move in another direction.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Tayari Jones: Thank you.
>> So I would just like to say
thank you, you've graced me
with your presence today.
I'm more than inspired because
I'm writing my first novel
and the title is His
Double Life, it's a story
about a small-town
hero who let's everyone
down in a love triangle
that he was in.
So you mentioned a love
triangle it's like, oh, yeah,
I'm doing something like that.
So what would be your advice
for me getting started
with a project?
I mean I've started it but
what can you give me to,
so that I have a good BookScan.
[Laughter]
>> Tayari Jones: I
honestly can't help you
with the BookScan but,
and also I almost hate
that I told you about
the BookScan.
>> I'm glad that you
did because I won't,
you know, be discouraged in se.
>> Tayari Jones: But I feel like
the thing, the writing business
and the writing are
two different things,
and I really encourage people
who are just starting out not
to find out anything
about the business
because no one has ever
come from a lecture
about the business
and felt like, oh,
I feel inspired to write now.
You always feel discouraged
by the business.
So, the one thing I would
say, yeah, find out as little
as possible about how it works
until you have your book done
because I want you to write a
book that speaks to your heart
and find an editor or an agent
that can sell what
you've written.
I don't want you trying to write
what they will sell, you see?
I want it to be all
about your unique vision.
If I had known when I wrote my
first book, in my first book
about growing up in Atlanta
during the child murders,
all the characters are
like 8 year olds and half
of the book is written
in the second person,
if I had known anything
about the business,
I never would have written
such a quirky, eccentric novel
because someone would have
said that will never sell,
but part of the benefit
of my early writing was
that no one was paying
any attention to me.
I never worried what
anyone would think,
I never thought anyone would
think anything so I didn't have
to be bold enough to put
the voices out of my head
because I felt like in many
ways I was this invisible person
doing something for my
own spirit, but if I had
to give you a concrete
piece of advice is this,
you know how people are always
saying writers write every day,
you have to write every day?
That is a myth.
You do and ought have
to write every day.
[Laughter] I feel that we tell
people that because we want you
to be consistent but I think
that what it accidently does is
that it sets a bar where
people who have busy lives,
people who work, people
who have children,
people who are doing elder care,
they feel they can't be writers
because they don't have enough
leisure time, and if we end
up with a canon of American
literature that's written only
by people with leisure time,
I feel like the most important
stories will be left out.
The reason why most of
us can't write every day.
[ Applause ]
We can't write everyday because
we're doing important work
and that's what needs
to be written about.
So, I say see if you can
write 3 times a week.
I feel, this is how I do it you
know how they tell you you go
to the gym 3 times a week?
When the rest of you
all are at the gym,
that's when I work on my books.
[Laughter]
>> Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi. Thank you so
much for writing a book
that captured the human
complexity of emotions
and nothing is black or white
and if I ever get married I'm
going to adopt a [inaudible],
but my question is
in an alternate world
if Roy did not go to jail,
do you think Celestial
and Roy would have
made it anyways?
>> Tayari Jones: Maybe.
I mean I feel that you never
know with any relationship
if it's going to work, right?
And also what does work mean?
I mean if you, because
you can look
at a relationship that's lasted
50 years but all that says is
that it has stood
the test of time
but that doesn't say
anything about the quality
of that relationship, right?
I mean sometimes relationships
end because they are healthy.
Sometimes relationships endure
because they are not healthy.
So I don't think the
question is whether
or not they would have made
it the question is whether
or not they would have
grown from the experience,
and I think that
they would have,
but I think it would
have been challenging.
I think that relationships
are challenging,
but this is what I also think.
Celestial and Roy are in a
situation they never have been
in and you know how,
and I think this is part
of the racial aspect
of it you know how
like if you're a black person
and people, when you're growing
up people tell you you have to
work twice as hard to get half
as much, you have
to be the best,
always have to be the best.
I feel like in the context
of their relationship
with him being wrongfully
incarcerated for them
to have made it I mean they
would have to have been twice
as good, 3 times as
good as other couples
to maintain their marriage.
Like what does it mean with that
idiom of you have to be so good
to even follow you into
your personal life.
I feel like that is one
of the many injustices
visited upon this couple.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi, I wish I was
as tall as you.
[Laughter] I'm very fortunate.
I've been able to get a book
[inaudible] a number of times
and the place I spend most of
my time is at Algonquin books
because I believe that the
books that are published
by Algonquin speak
to all aspects
of the life we should
all be learning about.
So they showed me your
book before I came out
and said you must
read this book.
And I wanted to ask
you how important it is
that your publisher have a
vision of where your work fits
into the world around you.
How important that is to
making you a better writer
and you a confident,
successful writer.
>> Tayari Jones: I do
think, I love my publisher.
I'm published by Algonquin
books through Chapel Hill.
I believe in independent
publishing
and they're an independent
publisher
and they have a small list.
>> Yes.
>> Tayari Jones: And every
book they publish is a book
they love.
They don't publish books they
don't plan to put forward.
It makes a big difference
to have an editor
that listens to the writer.
I mean my editor understood.
I was really worried with this
book that people would think
that because it has, that it
was a novel about prison, right?
That it would be filed
almost like sociology like,
almost like this was like
the new Jim Crow the musical.
I was really afraid that
that's how it would be,
but my editor he read it and
he said this is a love story,
and I knew that he understood
what I was doing because I think
that when you reduce
people to their problems,
I was told when I was training
as a writer they say you
should write about people
and their problems not
problems and their people,
and I was really pleased to have
an editor who understood this is
about people and their problems
and it does make
all the difference
in the world how it's packaged,
how they wanted to look,
how they talk about
it to other people
but the most important
thing about being
with an independent publisher
this book was 4 years overdue.
It was 4 years late.
And they wanted the book,
but they didn't pressure me
and they didn't try to get me
to give them whatever they had
so they could rush it to market.
Do you remember that,
do you remember those
commercials I think only people
of a certain age
remember that commercial
when the guy would say we
sell no wine before its time?
Remember that?
That's how they are with books.
They felt like the
book isn't ready,
it's like a cake you've got to
let the cake stay in the oven
as long as it needs to.
They're never going to publish
a cake that is still wet
in the middle, and I feel they
did that for me in this book,
and I will always be
grateful for the gift of time.
>> Ladies and gentlemen, we
have time for one more question.
>> Thank you for your book.
My question actually dovetails
with your last answer.
You mentioned the
new Jim Crow twice --
>> Tayari Jones:
-- you can wait.
I'll do more.
Okay.
>> Do you have, you mentioned
the new Jim Crow twice,
do you have other books that
were particularly impactful
or that you recommend either
fiction or non-fiction
that include like a
humane or a real personal
or lived experience
of incarceration?
>> Tayari Jones: You know the
thing that was most helpful
to me there's a book
from McSwiney's called Surviving
Justice and it is oral histories
of people who have been
wrongfully incarcerated
and the thing about it that
surprised me is that the people
who are wrongfully incarcerated
were more interested
in the reality of
incarceration for everyone.
Like they didn't hold themselves
up as I'm innocent, therefore,
this shouldn't happen to me.
They were more interested in the
way that prison affects everyone
like they didn't make a line
between wrongfully and imply
that there is, therefore,
a rightfully person
that's incarcerated
and that would be the book
that I recommend most,
but there's also Upstate
by Kalisha Buchanan
that's really good.
It's a [inaudible] novel.
It's all letters between
a young, young people
and the boyfriend
is incarcerated.
There's a lot, I'm
really excited
but you know then
there's the middle
of nowhere the feature film
by Ava DuVernay I
was really encouraged
by how many people are
talking about this issue
in different ways so
I never had to fear
that I wasn't writing
the definitive story.
>> Thank you.
>> Tayari Jones: Yes, ma'am.
>> Thank you for
writing this book.
Our book club just recently
discussed it a couple
of days ago and it was probably
one of the most heartfelt,
impactful conversions
we've had in a long time.
We're a group of all white
women with one Latina, so we,
I think we grabbed, it grabbed
us deep down and one of the
like book club questions
that are
out there is how did you
envision Roy's accuser?
>> Tayari Jones: I knew we
were going to get there.
I was thinking maybe
we weren't going
to get there, but we're here.
>> That was the one that I
asked and everyone in the room,
you know, envisioned her
white, and I did not,
I did not because I'm thinking
they're in a motel in the south
and I really didn't believe a
white woman would have talked
to him at that ice machine and
invited him back to their room
to help with whatever,
I can't even think
of what the issue was
he was helping her with.
And that really led to a really
deep soul searching conversation
amongst us.
So how did you envision her?
>> Tayari Jones: You know this
thing I don't identify the race
of the woman who accused
Roy and I didn't do it,
I didn't identify her
for a couple of reasons.
One is that I felt like
we could get derailed
from the rest of the story.
It was so tricky with him being
a black man falsely accused
of rape that in reading the book
I didn't want to like relitigate
so much of American history
and not be able to get forward
to the rest of the story,
which was about their marriage.
So I thought that I could
just like slide by that.
[Laughter] And also there's
this Toni Morrison story called
Racitatif about 2 girls
who are in foster care
and they're having all of these
racial conflicts throughout
their lives and she never tells
you which one of them is black
and which one is
write, and I teach
and if you teach your students
will almost come to blows
over which one they
think is black and white.
And so I thought would do
a little wink to Morrison
because I feel like every book
I've written I wink at her
in some way because I hope
one day she will notice me.
[Laughter] And so I don't
really go into it, but you know
when it's going to
cause me a problem?
I'm going to have to step up to
that because we're
making a movie.
[ Applause ]
And they have to, they
have to cast somebody.
I was like can't we
just put her in shadow?
They're like no, no.
So, I'm going to say the answer
to that question will be coming
to a theatre near you.
[Laughter]
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Tayari Jones:
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]